welcome to analog I'm Lisa foils here on
probably the most helpful show on the
internet we care about finding you more
games like the ones you already love and
today we're talking Dark Souls 2 the
brooding fantasy action RPG with
ruthless difficulty that is back to kill
you you loved it you braved it you
somehow miraculously finished it and now
you want more here are games similar to
Dark Souls 2 we'll assume you already
checked out Dark Souls 1 and Demon Souls
because well those would be similar to
Dark Souls 2 they're the same franchise
but you will also like Dragon's Dogma
what makes it similar to Dark Souls 2
well first they're both hack and slash
errs with survival horror elements plus
they both have huge open worlds
expansive fantasy settings that you can
explore at your own pace Francis and
during League are full of secret areas
branching off in odd ways allowing you
to have a hell of a good time exploring
the land before ever starting a story
quest Dragon's Dogma has a much more
in-depth story compared to the vague
plot of Dark Souls 2 though they are
both about revenge
in Dark Souls 2 you're on a quest to get
your curse removed and in Dragon's Dogma
you're after the dragon who ate your
heart that's not ok both games are sort
of grim brutal fairy tales
however Dragon's Dogma isn't as grueling
and lonely as dark souls 2 we all know
Dark Souls has one goal to kill you over
and over Dragon's Dogma is more
forgiving plus you have party members
called pawns both you and your main pond
are fully customizable and a lot of the
classes or vocations are similar in both
games I assure you you will die a lot
less in Dragon's Dogma though careful
when riding on a Griffin because that
thing will just tip you right off
my next suggestion has to be the Monster
Hunter games will say Monster Hunter 3
ultimate the combat will feel very
similar slow and deliberate with a focus
on timing evasion and health management
every game has boss battles but Monster
Hunter thrives on them these massive
detailed monsters that you fight require
clever strategy they don't have a health
bar so you'll just have to experiment
with different attacks until they
visibly start to wear down you'll still
have that open world field but a bit
less exploration the bonus here is the
lighter environment while the bleakness
of Dark Souls 2 just makes you want to
curl up in a corner and weep silently
Monster Hunter has lots of bright neon
colors that you'll never see in dark
souls oh and the monsters are just so
beautiful and once defeated you can use
their dead carcasses for sweet hats and
armor but I imagine that can't smell
amazing next screw lighter hearted maybe
you liked Dark Souls 2 because it was so
dark maybe you love being the brooding
loner
if so stepping into the boots of Geralt
from The Witcher 2 might be just what
you crave a great quote I've heard about
Dark Souls 2 is it has a great story you
just have to work for it if that's the
case in The Witcher 2 delivers you an
amazing story on a silver platter you've
been accused of killing the king oops
so you set out to find the real killer
but it's so much more complex than that
filled with political maneuvering tests
of your moral compass and trying to
determine just who to trust
tough decisions put you on dramatically
different paths it's a serious game but
still offers the occasional well time
joke from peculiar characters just to
keep things fun they've got some amazing
women at the brothel you should take a
look speaking of fun the combat is
visceral and satisfying in this amazing
RPG you are a monster killer though that
doesn't mean you still won't befriend
the occasional troll each battle really
requires intelligence in fact your
strategy in preparing for battle is
almost more important than your
performance in the battle itself
one final suggestion for the masochist
Dark Souls 2 is the ultimate display of
skill today but if beating it left you
thinking you're this amazing gamer who
can beat any game then I dare you to try
ghosts and goblins for the NES
this classic is one of the hardest games
ever made you're a knight trying to save
a princess from ghoulish horrors get hit
once and you lose your armor and you're
left running around in your undies get
hit a second time and you just die
you're just a pathetic pile of bones
test your skills test your sanity and
try not to have a brain aneurysm that's
really all we ask leave me a comment and
add to my suggestions which games do you
think are like Dark Souls 2 follow me on
twitter at lisa foils and come back next
week for another episode of analog